My teenage son has been consulting with you for his acting.
He did the Syrex tests and is off of gluten, dairy, sorghum, sesame, and buckwheat.
He likes the high protein organic yogurt made from coconut and cashew.
It has a gar in it.
He looked up that ingredient as wondering what your thoughts on that.
I think that is a thickening agent, so I'm sure you're fine on that.
Also, this brings up another point.
If you did the Syrex tests and you're off of certain foods, because of what test.
If you're off of a certain food because of the Syrex 10, Syrex array 10,
that Syrex array 10 tests for antibodies in foods, if you have antibodies in certain foods.
Remember, many of those will dissipate.
Gluten probably won't dissipate, but some of these other ones like sorghum and sesame
and buckwheat, those antibodies may be gone.
He may be able to introduce those foods back into his diet, probably not gluten and dairy
because I know what his issues are.
But the sorghum says to me in buckwheat possibly, so also consider that.
If you're staying off of the food because it's across-reacted to a self-antibody, an auto-antibody,
that's what it's called, that means an antibody to your own tissue.
Explain that.
So let's say if I have antibodies to my myelin, she sells in my brain and gluten is across-reacted
because it is, then you can't eat gluten no matter what.
So it's not because you have gluten antibodies, you're not staying off of them because you
have antibodies to gluten, you're staying off of it because gluten is across-reacted and
a molecular mimic to the myelin, she sells and you have antibodies to myelin, she sells.
So every time you have eat gluten, you're attacking your myelin, she sells.
You're causing myelin, she's destruction.
You're precipitating multiple myelosis, multiple sclerosis.
So you don't, that's a different reason to stay off food.
So no, it's because of the food antibody test, well, then some of those things could be
reintroduced as those antibodies dissipate.
No, I'm staying off it because I have, because you said it's a molecular mimic to the
thyroid, which gluten is a molecular mimic to the thyroid, so anybody that has thyroid
issues, hypothyroidism or and or Hashimoto should not be gluten.
So you don't eat it not because you have antibodies to gluten, which you may or may not have,
but you're not eating it because you have, it's a molecular mimic to the thyroid or whatever
tissue we're talking about.
I don't, that wasn't your question, but I think agar is just fine.